yes do you know what the average age of
death would come it is
according to official national
statistics
it's 82 years and three months
the average age of death normally 81
years
do you understand that we
because old people are dying do you see
this grass
the last line which had this much death
was 2008. that's the british medical
journal
no i came here to speak to this man not
your security
you have failed me thank you we i've
been a labor voter my entire life
you have failed to be the opposition
you've failed to ask where the lockdown
was
functioning just behind can we just do
you understand can we go anywhere
thousands of people have died because
you have failed to do your job
and ask the real questions well i am
telling you now and i hope this goes out
you have failed this country you have
seriously failed
you have allowed our children to wear
masks in school
when it's never been any evidence for it
on the front line
keeping people alive so i really don't
need lectures from you right about this
pandemonium
i am not bothering him that man is not
allowed
in my pub get out of my pub go on
yourself get out of my pub calm down
sorry can you keep out the way thank you